i spent some time yesterday talking
about
how the um reflexive reaction
from the republicans in charge of the
state of texas
to the power outages that are happening
tragically
in the wake of a storm and cold weather
were
blamed on anything on the left that
republicans could come up with we talked
about them blaming
the green new deal which of course
hasn't happened we talked about them
blaming wind turbines which of course
represent just a small fraction
of the energy generation in texas and
the truth is as
philip bump writes in the washington
post in a really good article that i
encourage you to check out
it has been extraordinarily misleading
what republicans have done when it comes
to
pointing fingers and and placing blame
in the state of texas for what is going
on
uh of course anybody talking about the
green new deal is
ignoring or misleading in the sense that
none of what texas decided to do with
their power grid
has anything to do with the green new
deal other than the fact that they've
done
a little bit of wind power okay and a
little bit of solar power
but the reality is that that represents
a very small percentage of texas's uh
power generation
and the truth about what's going on in
texas is a combination of
republicans who have opted in order to
avoid
what they call federal regulation of
their energy markets
have their own uh power grid
whereas just about i mean i i don't want
to go
hyperbolic but almost every other part
of the world
has a broader more interconnected power
grid
than just one state the way texas has
that puts texas at significant risk
in exactly situations like this but it's
not just that
it's also that they had a decade to deal
with exactly the issue they're having
now as we talked about yesterday
texas had a similar power outage
situation in 2011
a report was done tons of money was
spent on figuring out what happened and
how do you prevent it
from happening again and they figured
out how to prevent it from happening
again and it includes the
winterization of wind turbines but more
importantly
of instruments at natural gas
coal and nuclear power plants which are
the majority of texas
energy and they didn't do it they they
opted not to do that
other states that have wind power and
other types of cap power and
it gets cold places like montana and
wyoming and others
they've done the winterization so when
it gets cold the wind turbines work
everything works fine
okay so this is an example of a
republican stronghold
blaming a problem they in some cases
it's caused in some cases it's failed to
deal with
on democrats or the left or
progressivism or climate science or
whatever the case may be
and this is a trend this is something
that they have been doing
on the right for a very long time the
right does tax cuts
and the tax cuts rather than helping the
economy
don't help the economy because they give
the tax cuts to the rich and trickle
down doesn't actually work
and somehow they blame democrats they'll
do tax cuts for the rich and say this is
going to be great
it's not and then they say oh well the
problem is democratic social programs
the tax cuts for the rich would have
worked
were it not for the democratic social
programs the housing disaster in 2008
which of course was the result of under
regulation
of mortgages and uh of derivatives
from mortgages including the packaging
up of mortgages and selling them
you we we've talked about that really
it's a problem of under regulation
for a very long time uh uh primarily
under george w bush or most acutely
under george
w bush they said it's a cop you know
take your pick the list of things they
blamed is very
very long but some combination of uh
democratic policy
in cities that uh created a problem with
housing prices and
no the problem was under regulation led
by republicans dating back to
the sort of ideology of reagan in the
1980s the deregulation of the energy
industry more broadly
that's part of what we're seeing in
texas but but not only that has not
been good for states that have adopted
it as states have deregulated
energy under the idea of we want to give
people choice
and we want more competition and players
in the market everything from scams to
exploding prices have taken place
and by the way uh not with any increased
reliability when it comes to energy
but they blame it on the left um kansas
a very much uh cautionary tale
republicans including
the the governor there sam brownback
bankrupting kansas
going all in on trickle-down economics
and tax cuts for the rich or whatever
else
um completely bankrupt in kansas failing
to grow
the business base and the revenue base
and blaming democrats incoherently
they are now blaming covet deaths
and the fact that although coveted
deaths are i mean listen to the numbers
covid deaths are down 37 percent from
their peak a month ago
they are blaming covet deaths which they
didn't even seem to care about when
donald trump was president
40 of which were avoidable on joe biden
already
despite donald trump failing to control
it for nearly a full year
many of these stories in some way are
about either deregulation
or when it comes to covid not enough
federal government involvement but they
continue to
create these disasters blame it on
democrats even though they are the ones
in power
and also blame it on the ideology that
is the opposite of what they want when
really they should be looking at their
policies of getting government quote out
of people's lives
deregulation and so on if they're not so
so the the
the pattern is if they're in power and
there's a disaster they blame it on
democrats
because democrats somehow prevented them
from doing what they really wanted to do
or did something that played as a
counterweight to what they did
if republicans aren't in power they'll
just say democrats are in power so it's
their fault
even if their obstructionism is actually
what caused the problem
sort of like spoiled children no
accountability
no integrity no personal responsibility
they take credit for everything and
responsibility for nothing
much like donald trump i mean it's
donald trump took that idea that we've
seen republicans put into place over the
last 45
40 years and just exploded it to the
110th
percentile and unfortunately
it doesn't seem like things are super
quickly going to get any better in texas
i want to talk about that next
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wrist watch is the
perfect way
to elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one year
return policy and
five year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store
and free shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman